cassava a starchy root vegetable or tuba
holds a secret it thrives without the
help of fertilizers manure or pesticides
it's a robust plant Standing Tall even
in periods of drought but the wonders of
cassava don't stop there this humble
root is a Powerhouse of health benefits
packed with essential nutrients it's a
staple food for Millions around the
globe but hold on there's more cassava
can be a golden ticket to financial
prosperity
by cultivating this Hardy vegetable you
can reap not only nutritional benefits
but also monetary rewards intrigued to
learn more don't forget to hit that
subscribe button discover the magic of
cassava with us over and over again